ladies and gentlemen good evening I'm
absolutely delighted to be here to talk
to to Nick the obvious kind of question
is you're a very successful novelist
essayist you've written in all sorts of
other ways why would you bother with all
the complications and the collaboration
and the disappointment and the endless
development that writing for the screen
entails next year I will be celebrating
my 25th year of sitting on my own in a
room which I'll probably celebrate with
a flat check and an espresso and look at
the Guardian crossword same as every
other day I felt a few years ago that
something had to change if I was going
to keep writing rather than going on
endless committees and and literary
festivals and just doing something to
find some company somewhere and films
are nothing if not companionable there
are many other people involved and even
though it still comes down to sitting on
your own in a room writing for most of
it you work with very talented people
and then you if you're lucky get to have
some fun when the film comes out as well
a friend of mine who's an artist I saw
him one day and I said how was your day
and he said oh you know genius wanker
and and I couldn't believe that someone
else understood the way that I spend my
days
and of course the genius part lasts for
about five minutes and and and the
latter tends to last a lot longer in the
course of the day and and there are two
things with with films they think that
that help with that one is that when you
get to a certain point in your
novelistic career unless you really
really screw up badly the books going to
come out and and it's just you and you
don't particularly know how to judge it
and I guess the the genius rank of thing
then become comes into overdrive you'll
read a review that says you're a genius
you'll believe it and then read one says
the obviously you'll believe that but
for much longer with a screenplay there
are all these hurdles to jump over which
seem to have some kind of objectivity to
them and of course films don't always
work out but if you've written a
screenplay that attracts the interest of
a producer and then attracts the
interest of a cast and a director and
then finally and the biggest thing some
money to make the film then you feel I
think as if you proved something and to
yourself at least by that point and it
doesn't matter who you are as a writer
they are not going to fund you on the
back of your name basis of the direct
from the cast but not the writer so the
screenplay has to work and I enjoy that
though even though it is depressing and
it takes a long time I enjoy that the
jumping over hurdles and the other thing
from that is that I find it very
difficult to take pride in my work that
I've done by myself I think you're much
more likely to be critical of it then
than to really love it but the films
that I've been involved in even if I
winced at my own work I can take
enormous pleasure
the people's and and it feels like
something I can back you know seeing um
an education or Brooklyn for the first
time and seeing what loner chef that had
done and what John Crowley done and what
the amazing cast had done I felt very
glad to have been a part of it without
being entirely responsible for it when
you said that you were interested early
on possibly in becoming a screenwriter
was that because you had been aware but
when you watch films early on that there
was something driving them in in terms
of the actual craft of the writing
that's a good question I think the films
that I liked the most I think had
responded to the writing rather than
directional performance so things that
made a huge impression on me like quite
a few of the screwball comedies and I'm
particularly Robert Oakland's Nashville
which I saw when I was well 17 I guess
when it came out and I couldn't believe
that screenwriting could be like that so
loose and so you know had so much bottom
to it but it it did things that I hadn't
seen a movie do before I watched all of
these films after that say yes and I
think I was I was responding to to
writing because your first screenplay
was actually from one of your own books
good for fever pitch so did you do you
approach that in the way that you sort
of analyzed what you're going to do is
in terms of the craft or were you
thinking first of all this this is my
book and that this is the way I'd like
it to come over fever pitch thoughts
have happened it felt to me accidentally
when the book came out I was approached
by a young director who was working for
the Late Show and I got very excited
because he said he wanted to do
something about the book for The Late
Show and that seemed enormous to me the
book hadn't yet come out he said yeah
but what I really want to do is make a
movie of it
it wasn't as if I had
to be persuaded to do it because this
was 1992 I'd never written a novel I was
just about to become a father I was in
absolutely no position to turn down any
work and he said let's see if we can get
you some money to develop it and and
we'll go from there so I did it without
thinking about it really I just thought
well I don't know if this film will ever
be made but I'll just keep writing
drafts and and maybe someone will pay me
eventually
but we found very sympathetic people as
sympathetic young producer my my wife
used to sympathetic young producer she
was young and she was sympathetic we it
was it was the first time right the
first time produce the first time direct
and we just wanted to see how far we
could get and we got all the way to
production and Colin Firth and that
would that felt like phase one of a
screenwriting career because then I I
didn't only think for quite some time
but was there such a great revelation of
that from that first experience in terms
of the way it worked no good revelations
really I mean I learned that it all took
an incredibly long time and there was a
lot of messing about and at the time I
thought yeah I'm not sure this is this
is for me so the years go by and in the
meantime other people start adapting yes
but you weren't tempted at that no never
and the big thing about writing novels
is they take me two years and then the
idea that having put everything into
these books for two years you then spend
the next five taking two thirds of it
out again really doesn't strike me as a
very attractive proposition I'd rather
take stuff out of other people's books
you just left the people who adapted
your voice whether it was a bad boy or
uses better than Jeff
completely I mean both of those films
they took five years to and they
disappeared for long
patches of time I didn't know what had
happened to them the very strange
breakthrough with with high fidelity all
it was when I knew that it might happen
and I used to work on on Highbury Hill
which is the road that leads down to
Arsenal tube station and right next to
the tube station there's a kiosk that
sold cigarettes and newspapers are back
they used to buy my cigarettes and
newspapers of this guy was an Arsenal
family used to talk and one day he said
oh this bloke wants you to phone him and
he gave me a piece of paper and on the
paper it said Stephen Frears 2 to 7
something something something and that
was how I knew that Steve affairs was
going to make as I discovered a very
typically phrase in way of doing things
so an educational in Barbara's memoir I
mean how did that come up
and what was it particularly that
convinced you that that might be I read
this issue of Granta which had this six
page essay and I made about being
seduced by this older man when she was a
teenager
and you know it was a piece of
journalism rather than a short story so
it actually covered quite a lot of
territory and it seemed to have a
potential to say lots of things about
our country at the time but also a
particular mindset and it felt very rich
and also knew that we knew that no one
else was going to sort of chase after it
an option it so I said commander I think
this would be a great film and she went
off an option of the piece and when she
started to talk about who she would want
to employ to write it I suddenly felt
incredibly possessive of the material I
felt that I knew the character
and I knew the the film I wanted to see
so I asked if I could have a stab and
she very graciously for nought Pam's not
pay allowed me to have a go and we went
on from there and it took a long time
not just because it was hard to fund but
also it took a long time for me to find
the shape of it and that there were
several sort of breakthroughs I had
about the character which meant that he
became more complicated I think as as
things went on and something unusual
something a little bit bittersweet or
complicated those things are the things
that attract you yeah tonally that si
seemed to me to be a gift because it
made me laugh and it was shocking and it
seemed to have the power to move and I
think my tastes as a reader my tastes as
a TV watching us cinema our it's always
the same I don't like things that stay
in the same groove and it's one of my
big beats with a lot of literary fiction
that you can tell on page one that there
isn't going to be a joke for the next
300 pages and you know and it seems
crazy to me people laugh when they were
to parents funeral someone will make a
joke and you think how have you managed
to find the one sliver of 300 page life
that contains know if you know
whatsoever you know the trick and the
people I admire the most I think of the
people who couldn't turn on a sixpence
and and kind of make you laugh and then
and then punch her in the gut
emotionally and you know that seemed
that peace seemed to have the potential
to do that at least it was recognized I
mean you were Oscar and BAFTA nominated
for that screenplays there but then when
you go and you want to tackle a subject
that potentially is actually even more
difficult which is wild strains memoir
which has
a lot of walking and it has sex and it
has drug use and it's quite tough but
what you have there is you have a big
store attached to it beginning so how
does that change it well
one of the many happy byproducts of
being nominated for an Oscar was being
introduced to Ries at a party anyway we
we had a chat she said can I call you if
I come to London and she did and we went
out for a meal and she said well what do
you want to write and nothing really
came of that
and then I read Wilde I read it after a
beautiful review actually in the New
York Times and and and I ordered the
book straightaway and read it and
completely fell in love with it and
asked my agent find out whether the
rights are gone and if so to whom and
she came back and said well Reese
Witherspoon's bought it I thought okay
maybe I've got half a chance and I
emailed her straightaway and yeah it was
really different it was being developed
independently through Reese's company
there wasn't a studio involved but he
kind of knew that it would be made if
you got the script right and we were on
quite a tight schedule you know this was
in one way what I'd wanted I thought you
you want to see a clear path to
production but then you get home and
think oh the only thing that's stopping
this film from being might not be any
good once I finished it so I thought
well perhaps it was better the old way
dribble on for five years and no one
wants to make but I had a clear idea of
what I wanted to do with the book in
terms of the time scale of it and it's
such an amazingly packed book it's about
divorce and grief and and and drug abuse
and promiscuity and when I went through
making notes I realized that
I could easily write a two-hour movie
that would be quite compelling that
didn't have any walking in it and but it
is actually a film about a woman on her
own on a walk so it was really about
boiling everything down and and and
finding enough interesting things to do
on the walk you know there are all sorts
of sappy versions of that film I think
and maybe we made one but not in the way
that was the obvious pitfall which is
the kind of American Redemption story of
you know hard grit and you get somewhere
and I wanted to convey that the
impression I had for reading the book
which was that it wasn't about being
brave it was about having no other
choice whatsoever apart from having to
do this walk because she simply didn't
know what else to do and it's it's the
kind of miserable english- version of
doing an inspirational - which I do you
think was in Cheryl's book even though
she is you know old brave brilliant
American woman and the book is full of
inspiration but I think there is a kind
of desperation and recklessness in the
book that I wanted to preserve there's
no choice there's no fork in the road no
choice no fork in the road yeah however
with later drafts of scripts there are
choices folks in the road and sometimes
you may you know you may work with
directors or people later who will want
rewrites and you have to keep on and
then must sometimes come a point where
you think I think this script is good to
go but they don't
is that how I mean given that when
you're a novelist you're pretty much in
control until you start working with an
editor how hard is that in this regard I
think there are two types of director
there's the the kind of director who is
effectively an editor who wants to bring
this script to the screen and if there
is any obscurity or incoherence or
things that are not working then they
will suggest to you that there is a
better way or
or a more elegant way or a funnier way
of getting there that they are still
working effectively during development
as an editor I think in the way that I
would work with a book editor and then
there's another type of director is
basically an auteur I think who says
okay well this isn't this scene isn't
the kind of scene I want in my film so
it needs to be something else or it's
going to go completely and that is when
it gets hard I think as a screenwriter
because you've written you know I feel
as though they're books I feel as though
they're finished and ready to go and
Wilde was the hardest in terms of the
development process because we shall
mark is much more of a nature than
anyone I've worked with before and once
production actually starts do you are
you all set do you make or just they're
all you've done the end of the phone
thing um I've been asked to make changes
I don't I don't go to the set
people usually seem very disappointed to
see so you know I've usually paid a
polite visit and then got out it's I
mean as probably everyone in this room
knows it is staggeringly boring on a
film set I know I couldn't pick up the
first time I went when field pictures
being met I couldn't pick up the rhythm
of work at all because nobody seems to
be doing anything because they were
moving lights around and they were
fiddling and pedaling and you know when
you think that two or three minutes a
day is regarded as a stonking day's work
in film I think I'd rather do a fourteen
hour writing day and maybe write half
the script then then watch people move
lights around and and it is you know
once once it's all up and running then
it's a difficult relationship I think
between writer and director especially
for the writer because usually you
built some kind of bond in
pre-production and development which you
know it's thank god they they're not
interested in you anymore and it's kind
of sad new families yes think of a new
family they you are divorced and we they
have a new family and maybe there will
be a reconciliation when the film comes
out but not not until then well let's
let's move on to Brooklyn and come to
being novel which is now extremely well
known as a set text or quote all kinds
of things this did not seem to me at
least to be an obvious candidate to make
into a film because it is it's an or
without much dialogue and it's a novel
that builds up its atmosphere quite
slowly there's an offer all the things
that aren't set did it straight user
challenge initially I liked it that
there was no dialogue because that gave
me kind of creative free rein
it's not a very internal book I think
when when people have expressed surprise
or talked about its technical challenges
they've quite often said but it's inside
this girl's head but actually she's a
very watchful young woman and and most
of the things in the book are external
and and in fact Irish is it's maybe
quite opaque what I I think I did do was
turn the volume up and I hope it's not
too loud and vulgar but it that's what
it felt like doing was was was writing
the dialogue and just turning everything
up a little bit the humor and the the
heartbreak because you have less time to
do it and less time to work that the
atmosphere but column creates in the
book we had a read-through of the script
in in Dublin which is always an amazing
day I think for writer because it's the
only time you see the script performed
as it was meant
we performed and by the time the film
comes out there's a lot missing and
things have been changed and of course
it's all filmed out of order as well but
when they read it like a play then
that's the time it's most helpful to see
if your work has rhythm and where the
scenes are playing long or playing short
and and we had it was it was a wonderful
refund you've seen the film there's this
amazing cast of Irish girls were all
fantastic and Julie Walters and Jim
Broadbent and they were all there and
they were all great and it was it was a
very exciting day at the end Donal came
to me and he said I'm a scene short and
and of course actors always think
they're seeing leads but he made you
know a very passionate case for his
extra scene which was he said you know
I'm supposed to be offering her a choice
but we're never alone in a room together
and John and I were both sort of rather
dumbstruck by this observation I don't
think it's necessarily occurred to
either of us and one of the real
technical challenges of this film is
that she meets one guy kind of 1/3 of
the way through the film and the other
guy 2/3 of the way through the film and
you've got to try and find ways of
making the audience care about both of
them and and and feeling that you
genuinely is on the horns of a dilemma
and the book is incredible at doing that
I think because when you read it a
second time you cannot believe how late
Jim comes in to the book and it's sort
of 4050 pages that he has to play with
and you think this isn't going to work
because you know that she's going to be
here back into this life but he can't
believe that he's going to come up with
a convincing case for this life and and
he does and that's the challenge that we
all had to respond to so Donal said he
needs a scene where
is on his own with her and I thought
that's completely fair enough and we
were in this production office in in
Dublin and I I went upstairs and I
borrowed somebody's computer and I wrote
the C in probably 30 minutes and and
said to John what about something like
this and this mirrors the scene that she
has lieutenant beginning he said well
I'll try it and then he came back and he
said so sure and they'll like it and
they were to try it they did it and I
can't believe that it survived into the
film not that there's anything wrong
with it but it kind of drives you mad
that you spend four years writing the
rest of it and a half an hour writing
has seen that sort of gone through
intact but that all of course all comes
from having thought about these
characters on and off for four years and
and from Donald's input and that's the
real beauty of film as as collaboration
where these very fine actors have
observed from their perspective what is
wrong with your script and and they've
given suggestions as to how to improve
it and if you don't listen to that I
think they're mad the thing that keeps
coming back all the way through this is
the status of the screenwriter and the
status of the screenwriter as opposed to
the status of the director because we do
still live in a rather you know an area
where apart from the star start the
director is the star and and films are
regularly described as belonging to a
director even though the whole idea may
originally be the writers do you think
that's wrong well I don't really
understand how it's taken hold
actually I mean as I understand it the
auteur theory was invented simply
because it seemed so unlikely rather
than it was obvious it was a
counterintuitive thing which now seems
to have stuck that the director is the
author despite not authoring anything at
all
but I find it
mystifying particularly when it comes to
things like reviews and routinely things
are attributed to a director that you
know he can't possibly have done that
the director did not invent these
characters probably did not invent this
time scale order or you know there are
things that can be done in editing of
course and there are directors
responsible for an awful lot but the
writers the author describing a
director's as somehow been the author of
them while owning the film or having a
possessory credit
I'm just mystified as much as anything
great but let's have some questions from
authors directors whoever all the
adaptations you've made
apart from favorite page had in their
centers women and you've described all
the process and all the stories behind
your decision so far but is it
coincidental that it was you were drawn
to stories about main female characters
yes right I don't know what say I find
myself curiously drawn to beautiful
young actresses as I get older and I I
can't I don't know what that's about
first of all I did I couldn't think of
anything else to say about young men
after those first two or three books and
and there's something in some ways I
think more dramatic about the stories of
young women because it quite often
involves some kind of oppressions a
strong word but you know when you when
you live in the West but you know young
women who have have to overcome
obstacles or deal with a set of rules
that are not of their making and there
is something I think inherently more
dramatic for a screenwriter about that
also not many people seem to be doing it
there is a constant complaint about
parts for women there was a big debate
about the Oscars last year where every
single nominated film just about was
about men and we have this phenomenal
acting talent of young women and older
women in fact you I don't think being
given enough to do so I'm I'm very happy
to be given a clear field
I fear that other people will realize
what a good time I have and steal my
thunder but you know I think young women
and I guess period as well Brooklyn and
an education where the rules again
they're much clearer we still love Jane
Austen even though those rules are
absurd to us because we like the clarity
of it just a simple question how old
does being oscar-nominated change you as
a writer does it's you know because
obviously you've talked about you're
getting working with Reese Witherspoon
wood they were were there other projects
that you had and you know how does that
change it was as a writer does it put
more pressure on you or I've found that
if you're an oscar-nominated
screenwriter the only way that people
ever know about it is if you introduce a
conversation by saying I'm an
oscar-nominated screenwriter
I mean you a lot remembered from the
introduction I was asking ah yes so I
think the information probably last for
about an hour but you'd be surprised how
few people noticed at the time I think
that the only way to get work is by
doing good work really and for me the
the real point of something being good
is that it buys me another gig not not
because of the money but because that's
what I want to do and and the better the
work you've done the better the jobs
he'll go to the offered so I mean to be
fair
once I had got the Oscar nomination then
the offers were a lot more frequent I
guess but most of its rubbish so it
doesn't really make any difference I
wouldn't touch most of it in a thousand
years and like really really bad really
you can't believe how bad list of the
projects out there are and and then you
realize what fills up multiplexes well
just about I've got one final question
for you which is about Original
Screenplay as opposed to adaptations
we've been talking about adaptations and
indeed if you look at most of the films
they are even if it's from you know
magazine article do you regret the fact
that there are so few original
screenplays the note of caution actually
is to say that most people don't know
that there were books in the first place
we are this is quite a rarefied audience
and you know you're a very well-read
person but even something like Brooklyn
which we think of as being a hit book
nobody's ever heard of it and nobody
knows who wrote it I once had an
argument with a woman on a plane about
whether I'd written high fidelity
it was a very embarrassing and
unfortunate argument I started talking
to him we started talking about films so
she said her favorite film was high
fidelity and I said oh that's funny
I write the book and she said it wasn't
a book I said well it actually was I
really did write it and she said I've
watched that movie so many times if that
was a book it would have said at the end
and I would have seen it I said we sort
of she's just fell into a rather grumpy
silence we didn't speak to each other so
it's it's only a certain section of the
population that cares that there are so
few original screenplays I think and
then of course we see rather
inexplicably the books then go into the
bestseller list when people have seen
the films which isn't the way that a lot
of us want to do things but that's what
happens I love doing it up tations
because I think there comes a point in
your career when you maybe get sick of
who you are and however many different
ideas you try and come up with and how
however different I try and make the
books I am me and I have my voice and I
have my concerns and my style and if I'm
given something like wild I think I
could never have written this book in a
million years you know I'm not a woman
I've never been on a hike but I can use
whatever skills I have as a dramatist
and I can access this material and I've
started to think of it a bit like the
end of The Truman Show where Jim Carrey
bumps up against the sky and I feel as I
get older I'm constantly bumping up
against the inside of my skull I think
oh I've got some this is new this is the
so it feels fresh to do Brooklyn to do
well to do an education well thank you
very much for questions but most of all
for your insights
and I hadn't learned to lesson that if
you if you've got a reputation for a
second of doing quality stuff you've got
to keep the quality up and beside that
the quality sink and I had to have
another boost to it you know with for
weddings - he said children are just
people who simply haven't lived as long
as we have so there's no need or reason
to talk down to them as though they are
from another planet
you